hi everyone my name is camera chambers
and this is Tara's never seen I tried to
wait I tried to milk it for all it was
worth
let some time go by not watch an Edgar
Wright film so close to the last Edgar
Wright film but I couldn't do what
everyone today I thought I would start
the trilogy the Cornetto that was called
the ice cream trilogy a lot of times I
watch movies for this series cameras
never seen and I'm excited to see them
because I will now get references from
that film and like I just should see
some film but a lot of them I don't have
so much excitement for all of these like
anytime from now on that I get to see a
new Edgar Wright so I'm just going to be
very excited about it like I would be
much more excited to see Shaun of the
Dead than I think the original planet of
the age is like it's a film I know I
should watch probably at some point but
I just don't see myself like loving it
does that make sense so this I'm just
very excited to jump in I said give me
the shot of the dead prediction hashtag
camera's never seen and then there's a
really adorable picture of I all right
everyone let's jump into this together
with shot of the dead
[Music]
yes yes it was so good and usually for
these episodes I write five or six pages
of notes up to like a 13 15 pages of
notes this I wrote a page and a half it
didn't need to be commented on because
it's damn near a perfect film it's so
good it's also so much more emotional
but I thought it was going to be it had
so much heart in it I really thought it
was going to be a comedy and and just so
the first half really isn't a zombie
movie at all second half zombie movies
but intertwined throughout it's a really
nice emotional moment I cried and it was
not something that I was expecting at
all
I thought the main character was so much
more interesting and great in this he
was similarly to Scott Pilgrim he was
kind of like lost and kind of a dud but
he wasn't a jerk he was just a little
stuck in his life at the moment the
relationship made so much more sense
than in Scott Pilgrim and Scott Pilgrim
I didn't understand why any of these
women would be with him and this his
girlfriend was like oh we're not going
to be together anymore this is gonna be
hard for me because I do love you but
you're not doing anything man story-wise
and relationship wise and wade made way
more sense Nick Frost is one of the
roommates
he is extremely unlikable character I
wrote down at one point I don't like
Edie he doesn't have any redeeming
qualities and his renting impression
isn't even good he does end up redeeming
himself in the end and the very end of
the movie where it's shown that he is in
their shed and he just gets to play
video games a zombie all the time now
great great ending throughout the film
had a difficult time but kind of
enjoying him just some of the phrasing
that he used and just like I said I'm
not
many redeeming qualities until the end
but um he what he was a great actor and
him and Simon Pegg are a fantastic
singer but the other roommate Peter
Saracen no way Saracen Alex salon last
name he was in parks recreation and I
love this part except so much and so he
popped up as the other roommate I was so
excited already the whole cast is really
great
bill night that his name's last name
he's hilarious and was just wonderful it
was especially his Redemption scene was
incredible Martin Freeman I love it it
was so much the beginning of the movie
there is a very long shot of him leaving
his apartment his flat and walking down
the street to the store to get a coke a
bit later on in the movie they do the
same exact shot but this time they're
zombies scattered around and there's
bloodstains on the fridge for the coke
and it's all exactly the same but but
just like a sprinkled in zombies and he
doesn't realize that there's friggin
zombies and it's so well done and so
cool but it's exactly the same it's just
it's really that's a love of the movie
just slowly casually turns into a zombie
sizzle and you see bits in spurts of of
there there being oh a zombies on the
news or like the papers talking about it
and just a little hint every once in a
while and it's just slowly but surely
tearing into resolving though and it's
great
there was a oh I just wrote Oh Mary
oh no oh girl it's a cute funny solid
film at first and then you realise it's
a zombie film I know I already knew it
was this obviously obviously but you
know the characters realize it's a
zombie film and it just it gets so good
after that my all-time favorite theme in
the movie is when they're trying to get
rid of some zombies and they're trying
to find weapons and they bring out their
box of Records and they're going through
the treacherous no that's that's the
first pressing album can't use that
Batman Sam track okay yeah let's do that
as I throw it out him and it's it's so
funny the time that they take to go
through their records and those kind of
things were
what really works for me between Sean
and Edie it's when Ed was just being
like a selfish brat jerk didn't really
work couldn't really understand but
that's I mean the whole foot is that
like he had to grow a bit and Sean also
had to realize that he couldn't rely on
this unreliable person so it makes sense
definitely didn't bother me as much as
my dislike for sock nope so Sean needs
to validate in his mind that he can make
a plan he can take charge and get things
done and so they go to pick up Sean's
mother and stepfather and the
stepfathers been bitten you you got it
you see that shadow Kate's this of other
and this is incredible
seen with so many feelings in an emotion
it's so good where the step dad is dying
and then he says that he's sorry and
that he had always loved Sean and
there's this incredible scene when he
died and it Sean's like crying and it's
where did that come from why am I
feeling these feelings in this comedy
like horror zombie satire film what once
they go and they get the girlfriend and
her two roommates and they go to the bar
lotta stuff happened in between this but
at the bar Sean's mother and up getting
bitten and and she passes away and he
has to shoot her because they're all in
this confined space and they don't want
her to change and eat them make sense
but it is emotional a ask you guys Simon
Pegg is such an underrated actor
I know I've seen him in something else I
know I have but I don't know what that's
what I feel with a lot of the British
talent in this I know I've seen them in
things like I feel like I've seen every
single one of them in black mirror out
that's probably not from where he is
show outrageously good he's funny and
and dry then you have to kill your
mother and he just you know first on the
water words and I have cried at this
moment it was so good the Winchester has
a jukebox and it perfectly narrates the
scenes that are happening in the film as
we saw with baby driver if you haven't
seen it go see it right away
where are you watching this the music is
such an important role in Edgar Wright
filled and sings here like just it is so
much justice by the end you'll have red
stuff on you I love to say everyone
called it red stuff it's not like your
Penley you've read stuff you'll be an
expert at how to plan your survival for
a zombie apocalypse Ike will surely be
your greatest asset
do you think you would be a really good
asset for zombie apocalypse I mean I
stood to go to yes you've got long nails
and a lot of fat
when spoilers it comes to shun having to
kill his mom you'll cry God dang did I
cry also I always feel like I should say
spoilers in this but I'm like no the
whole premise of the show is that
everyone has seen these people if you
love the scene where Diane gets everyone
acting lessons before trying to pass as
zombies I loved that scene I loved Diane
she's a drama teacher and she is such a
drama teacher like you look at her and
you're like I wonder what she is
probably a drama teacher like perfect
casting perfect you'll immediately want
to watch Hot Fuzz and world and also
you'll love the don't stop me now
sequence yes yes yes and yes yes yes yes
I imagine you guys know what the next
two weeks are going to be because I
don't think I want to take a break from
watching these films we'll see how this
does but great I'm actually on time for
a prediction and it's for a movie I
haven't seen well you still mentioned
I'm sorry Tamra no I mean I'm sorry I'll
stop doing it when you stop laughing
well that was incredible I loved it with
all of my heart don't start iknow
don't stop iknow cuz we're having a good
job having a good time good
[Music]
[Applause]
you